mesdames et messieurs shalom et
bienvenue à bord du vol
elle y 971 de tel aviv à abou dhabi
c'est le capitaine talent becker qui
parlent ce lundi 11 heures le vol elle y
971 s'apprête à décoller un numéro de
vol qui n'a pas été laissé au hasard
ils portent les mêmes chiffres que
l'indicatif téléphonique de sa
destination
les émirats arabes unis à son bord une
délégation israélo américaine piloté par
le gendre de donald trump pour jared
kushner c'est une période pleine
d'espoir mais je crois que beaucoup de
paix et de prospérité sont possibles
dans cette région et dans le monde
entier
une volonté d'apaiser les tensions dans
la région inscrits à même le cockpit en
trois langues
pis salam et shalom objectif pour y
parvenir
multiplier les échanges dans de nombreux
domaines notre objectif est d'obtenir un
plan de travail commun pour faire
progresser les relations dans un large
éventail de domaines tourisme médecine
innovation sciences technologies santé
économie et bien d'autres sujets et déjà
en signal d'amélioration des relations
dans la région l'arabie saoudite alliée
des etats-unis a accepté la traversée de
son espace aérien par le vol elle y 971
une première là aussi mais un voyage qui
crée quelques turbulences
le gouvernement palestinien ne voit pas
d'un bon oeil cette entente
il nous est possible aujourd'hui de voir
atterrir un avion israélien aux émirats
dans une violation flagrante de la
position arabe sur le conflit israélo
arabe
15h48 atterrissage à abu dhabi et
réponse aux critiques palestiniennes
les très rares qui ont critiqué cet
accord de paix sont ceux qui ont une
longue expérience des chèques piégeant
leurs propres peuples dans la misère et
la pauvreté
il exploite la division pour maintenir
le pouvoir mais leur rhétorique s'est
fatiguée la région se libère de leur
emprise
même si pour le moment aucun autre vol
commercial n'a été programmée entre les
deux pays
le vol elle y 971 pourrait ouvrir la
voie à une longue série de destinations
à partir de tel aviv
la semaine dernière le chef de la
diplomatie américaine mike pompéo s'est
rendu au soudan à bahreïn et à oman pour
tenter de convaincre d'autres états de
la région de suivre l'exemple émirati